ils doivent s'affronter en simple puis
en double pour totaliser suffisamment de
points et faire gagner leur équipe
chez les hommes le tennis club des trois
îles et reçoit les guadeloupéens de
saint-françois des équipes championnes
en titre dans leur région mais qui pour
la première fois vont se retrouver face
à face aux trois îles et on compte sur
hugo bokassa champions 3e série et
laurent crépieux le mieux classé est
champion du pile 45 ans on habitude de
parler de tennis en mode individuel ça
change quoi de jouer en mode et qui bien
qu on représente son club qu'on soutient
le capitaine ne peut intervenir pendant
pendant les matchs afin de donner des
conseils et puis et puis après il ya le
double qui aussi à une partie
intéressante ce qu'on se retrouve à des
contrôles même principe côté féminin
l'équipe championne de la martinique
c'est la s contre et de chercheurs cinq
fois consécutive championne régionale
elles ont aussi remporté deux des trois
dernières confrontations face à la
guyane avec une compétition qui s'ouvre
désormais sur un vrai championnat
antilles guyane c'est l'occasion d'une
plus large adversité le capitaine n'y
voit que du bonus c'est vrai que ces
dernières années c'était toujours les
mêmes qui se rencontrent et on se
connaissait déjà
maintenant c'est une c'est un nouveau
format je trouve ça très bien et ça va
créer une émulation ne serait ce que sur
le championnat l'année prochaine donc il
y aura encore beaucoup plus d'engouement
pour que cette ce championnat antilles
guyane puisse perdurer pour l'ego
aérienne de mautauban par contre c'est
la découverte complète d'autant que dans
l'effectif de guadeloupe elles n'ont que
13 et 15 ans il faut donc apprendre à
gérer le stress et à se forger une
expérience nous on a quand même une
équipe de jeunes
qui des jeunes filles qui est visible à
l'international et de nous on veut aller
toujours vers l'avant ou s'il veut qu'on
veut aller vers la victoire en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on prenne toujours c'est des
cons sur la compétition on vise la gagne
demain c'est au tour de la guyane de
rentrer en lice toutes les équipes vont
se retrouver pour trois simples et en
doubles
la victoire se jouera au plus grand
nombre de points obtenus